So we're beginning at December the 22nd, 1904 in Volume 6.
And the heading is that the more the soul is empty and humble, the more the divine light
fills her.
Now, we're coming, therefore, to something that is absolutely key to the whole divine
will experience, and that is that unless we empty ourselves, there's no room for God.
Is that all right?
If I want to fill this with something else, I have to empty it of the water that's in
it.
That's the logic.
So Louisa says, "As I was in my usual state, I saw little baby Jesus with a fistful of
light in his hand."
Now that seems a very simple image, but an actual fact, it's an image of the omnipotence
of God, because he alone is the author of light, and God is light.
I remained enchanted, and he told me, "My daughter, perfection is light," as a major
statement that's made there.
One John, one five, God is light, okay?
Perfection is light, that means that we have to be transformed to the point where we become
light.
Now Jesus asked for that in Matthew 5, 17, that were to be the light of the world.
And one who says he wants to reach it, this light, acts just like one who would want to
clasp a body of light in his hand.
He tries to clasp, but the light itself flows through his fingers, except his hand remains
immersed in that light.
Now the light is God, and God alone is perfect, that's Luke 18, 19, God alone is perfect.
And the soul who wants to be perfect does nothing but sees shadows, the little drops
of God, and sometimes she does nothing but live in the light alone, that is in the truth,
that's John 14, 6, I am the way, the truth and the life.
And just as the light penetrates deeper and occupies more space, sorry, as the light penetrates
deeper and occupies more space, the greater the void it finds and the deeper the place
is, in the same way, the more the soul is empty and humble, the more the divine light
fills her and communicates his graces and perfections to her.
Now God is the source of light, we have to be transformed into God, therefore we have
to be transformed into light, but it can't happen if we don't put the ego aside, it's
actually quite simple.
So in the divine will adventure, which I like to call it, the motto has to be not my will,
but thine be done.
And if the Lord knows that you are serious about putting aside your will, he'll give
you loads of opportunities, he'll get awfully excited, okay.
So December 29, 1904, most of the time human weakness is lack of vigilance and lack of
attention.
Now that is a very important statement, very important, okay.
Because what he's saying is that if we were vigilant and we were watching things, we wouldn't
fall into half the faults and difficulties and sins that we do.
That's what he's saying.
So Louisa said, "As I was in my usual state, I was thinking about the most humiliating
steps that our Lord suffered, and I would feel horror within myself.
But then I would say to myself, Lord, forgive those who renew for you these sorrowful steps,
because the weakness of man is too great.
At that moment, blessed Jesus came for a little and he told me, my daughter, that which is
said to be human weakness most of the time is lack of vigilance.
Now you need to call her that and underline it and put an envy beside it and everything
else.
Most of what is said to be human weakness is actually a lack of vigilance and of attention
from one who is the leader, that is from parents and superiors.
In other words, somebody in charge of a child can train a child to goodness.
But if you don't pay attention and you're not vigilant, then the child will fall into
all kinds of problems.
Is that correct?
But it's true of us as adults as well that we let ourselves off the hook and just simply
say that it's human weakness.
The Lord says, no, no, you're not paying attention.
You're not looking at what's going on.
In fact, when a person is watched over and checked and is not given the freedom she wants,
not receiving this nourishment, the weakness is destroyed by itself.
Now, that was one of the purposes of men and women going into community life and dedicating
themselves to a religious life so that they would have this discipline upon themselves
day and night to help them to overcome their weaknesses and become saints quickly.
Okay.
That was the plan, if I can put it that way.
So the weakness would be destroyed by itself while yielding to one's weakness is simply
the nourishment of becoming worse.
So every time we yield to that weakness, the thing gets worse.
And one of the gravest mistakes we make is to say, oh, but I was always like this.
And if a person says, I was always like this, what they're saying is, I've no intention
of changing.
And so what they've done is they've blocked themselves from going forward and they can
make life hell for people trying to live with them.
Okay, then so you can see that somebody living in the divine will has got to be very open
to change because you'll have to change all the time if you're to be transformed into
light.
Then the Lord added, am I daughter, just as the soul becomes impregnated with virtue like
a dry sponge becoming soaked with water, that is with light, that means we become soaked
with light.
Now, light in these writings represents the divine will, so he becomes soaked with the
divine will.
And so he becomes soaked with beauty and grace and love, some of the great attributes
of God who is beauty and love.
In the same way, sin and weaknesses that one yields to impregnate in the soul like a sponge
becomes like mud, you're absorbing darkness instead of light.
You see, the opposite of light is darkness.
And if the Lord uses the term mud, now it's not only with Louisa but also with other saints,
he uses the expression mud, meaning the things of the earth that pull you back way further
down than even being an ordinary Christian because you see, we were made from mud, if
I can put it that way.
So you're brought back to nothing, you're brought back to destruction.
And so mud represents sin accepted, worldliness accepted, and therefore you're out of the
spiritual life completely.
So soaked with mud, that is with darkness and ugliness and even with hatred against God.
Now you'll be shocked maybe at that language, but words that are used in Louisa's writings
are used in the same way as in the Bible.
And hatred means to repudiate, to push away, whereas the modern use of that word means
to reach out to destroy or kill.
Okay, so it's a different meaning of the word.
So I want to give you Luke 11, 34 to 36 for that, Luke 11, 34 to 36.
So January 21, 1905, one who dishonors obedience, dishonors God.
Now one of the things about Jesus is that obedience was the very center of his life.
And I'm going to give you a summary of John's gospel, okay?
I'm going to give you one after the other, they're all texts from John and they're literally
a summary of this gospel, okay?
And the heading you give it is that Jesus did the will of the Father.
Jesus did the will of the Father and he's our model with no other model.
So John for 30, 534, 638, 828, 829, 855, 1029, 1038, 1250, and 1431.
Have you got that?
Now in those texts, Jesus says, I always do the will of my Father.
I don't do my own will.
I only reveal what the Father tells me to reveal.
I only teach what the Father tells me to teach.
The Father and I are one, okay?
And it culminates in 1431 with these incredible words.
What Jesus says, I want the world to know that I love the Father and therefore I do exactly
what my Father tells me.
Now that's what Louisa is being trained to live is those words, to prove that she loves
the Father by doing exactly what the Father wants.
And this obedience to God and to his law has got to come into us as well.
So this is January the 21st, 1905, it's only a few lines.
After I expose certain doubts to the Confessor, my mind could appease itself with what he
said to me.
Then when blessed Jesus came, he told me, my daughter, if one reasons over obedience by
merely reasoning over it, he dishonors it and one who dishonors obedience dishonors God.
Now what he's saying is, when you start rationalizing it, now the thing that has destroyed religious
life today is the simple thing that there is no obedience even though they have taken
vows.
What they do is, and they'll tell you themselves, just ask them, you don't have to ask me,
what they will tell you themselves is that the superior wants something done and the
person who is to do it will come and talk it all out and agree only to what they will
do.
That's not obedience.
That's rationalizing and that you will decide, I'll do it under my conditions my way and
I'll only do the bits I want, that's not obedience.
Obedience is completely different, it's surrender.
And obedience is a very powerful thing.
In fact Jesus says that the person who is truly obedient can conquer their own self much quicker
than anybody else because you're letting your own will go aside for the sake of somebody
else's and we actually need that experience if we're going to know how to surrender to
God in the divine will.
So September the 28th, 1905, the cross is the seed of virtue and there's no way out
of the cross because you know what you're doing the hours of the passion that Jesus says
that when he took up the cross he put you and me into it and that was that each one
of us was given a place in the cross therefore all of us together have got to carry that cross
to Calvary, all of us together meaning the whole church.
So Louisa said as I was feeling in suffering more than usual, my adorable Jesus came for
just a little and he told me.
My daughter, the cross is the seed of virtue.
And just as one sows harvest for 10, 20, 30 or even 100 in the same way the cross being
seed multiplies virtues and perfections and it embellishes them in an admirable way.
Now for the subject of the seed go to Matthew 13 23, Matthew 13 speaks about the sower and
the seed.
So the more crosses tick in around you, the more seeds of virtue are sown in your soul.
Now what he's saying there is when a cross or a difficulty or a trial comes to you.
That's your opportunity for growing in patience, growing in kindness, growing in love, growing
in humility, growing in forgiveness, growing in everything, that's what he means.
So the very fact that a cross has been laid upon you is the opportunity to grow in all
of these things and he says that, well he doesn't say it here, but other people say
it outside of this text, a Christian without a cross is an anachronism.
Therefore instead of afflicting yourself when a new cross comes to you, you should rejoice.
Now Louisa will tell you in the higher volumes that when you're going through a time of difficulty
or trial, what you say to the Lord and I've had an opportunity to do this since Christmas
every day, every solitary day, I adore your holy dispositions towards me and that means
you accept carte blanche what he has sent to you regardless of the human circumstances.
Otherwise are the wherefores, the right or the wrongs or anything else, I adore your
holy dispositions towards me and you give them a chance to work with you.
So therefore instead of afflicting yourself when a new cross comes, you should rejoice.
Thinking that you are acquiring another seed with which you can enrich and even complete
your crown, so that's Matthew 13, 31 to 32.
So February the 8th, 1905, we're talking about the characteristics of the children of God,
love of the cross, now notice love of the cross, not just tolerance of it, love of the glory
of God and love of the glory of the church.
Now notice there's nothing selfish there at all, nothing for me.
Continuing my poor state of privation and of unspeakable bitterness, Louisa said, Jesus
makes himself seen in silence and you know now that means that he's chastising.
And he told her, my daughter, the characteristics of my children are love of the cross, love
of the glory of God and love of the glory of the church to the point of laying down their
lives.
Besides that, I want you to put Romans 829, Romans 829 that we would be in the image of
the son.
One who does not have these characteristics in vain calls them my son.
One who dares to say it is a liar and a traitor who betrays God and himself, which is very
strong language.
Take a look at yourself and see what you have to be said to her, okay.
And no wonder he disappeared, okay, that was in case she'd react.
February the 10th, 1905 and this talks about what the contentment of the soul are about.
Louisa said, I was in my usual state and I felt a discontentment about myself and when
blessed Jesus came, I felt myself entering into such contentment that I said, "Allor,
you alone are my true contentment."
And he said, and I say to you, the first contentment of the soul is God alone.
Now that's exactly what Teresa of Avila said, God alone sufficed.
She was 16th century as you know, God alone sufficed.
So the first contentment is God alone.
The second contentment is when the soul within herself and outside of herself looks at nothing
but God.
There goes your late, late show.
The third one is when as the soul finds herself in this divine sphere, no created object nor
creatures nor riches can break the divine image within her mind.
Now, you see, the terrible problem that we have is that we're inundated with television,
internet, gadgets, radio, you name it, they're all there, saturating your mind.
It's extremely difficult to come to a point where you can have the divine aspect all the
time.
I have to say it here, I've been kind up to now, you have to turn off some of these gadgets.
You have to turn them off because you can't, we've only got one mind.
You can't be switched into all of these worldly channels feeding all their worldly ideas and
switched into God at the same time, it doesn't work.
Have you ever tried praying after the late, late show or something like that?
It wouldn't work.
Why?
Because your mind is full of anything that's not God.
Even if they're talking about exorcism.
So the third is when the soul finds herself in this divine sphere, no created object nor
creatures nor riches can break the divine image within her mind.
In fact, the mind nourishes itself with what it thinks.
Look at that.
And by looking at God alone of the things down here, she looks only at those that God
wants, not bothering about anything else, and so she remains always in God.
The fourth contentment is suffering for God because in order for the soul and God to maintain
their conversation, to be more intimately clasped together and to prove their love to
each other, God calls the soul and the soul answers.
God draws near to the soul and embraces him.
God gives her suffering and the soul gladly suffers.
I adore your divine dispositions towards me.
And rather, she desires to suffer more for love of him so as to be able to say to him,
"Do you see how I love you and this is the greatest of all contentment?"
We have a way to go, haven't we?
Yeah.
But one of the big ways to get there is to turn off the gadgets because they're an absolutely
mactimum distraction.
February the 24th, 1905, I love this, humility is a flower without torns.
I mean, we love the rose, but it has torns, hasn't it?
Okay.
This morning, blessed Jesus came for just a little, and he told me, "My daughter, humility
is a flower without torns.
It doesn't damage anybody.
It doesn't damage yourself, it doesn't damage anybody else.
Humility never attacks, ever."
Okay.
So you'll have a way of finding out how much of it you have.
And because it is without torns, it can be held in one's hand, it can be clasped, it
can be placed wherever one wants without fear of being bothered or pricked, or the roses
will tell you whether you touch the Marnal, such is the humble soul.
One can say that she does not have the pricks of defects.
Look at that.
And since she is without pricks, one can do with her whatever one wants.
Now who is it that wants to pick up the soul and hold it in his hand and hold it to his
heart and all the rest of it without pricks?
It's the Lord.
So he doesn't want us attacking him while he's actually picking us and wanting to love
us and all the rest of it.
And he says, "To be a rose without torns, you have to go up the humility."
Okay.
In other words, humility is mild.
Now that is blessed are the meek, they shall inherit the earth.
So that should be Matthew 5'10", I think it is.
Maybe it's further than that, but it's to be attitude.
Matthew 5.
And since she is without pricks, one can do with her whatever one wants.
Not having torns, naturally she does not prick nor cause bother to others.
So a humble person is very easy to live with because they're not prickly towards anybody
else either.
But there are some people who are so prickly that you have to be very careful how you say
"good morning".
It might be the right way to do it, and you might have forgotten to give them a brilliant
smile to go with it, and you'll get it back.
I'm sure you've never met anybody like that.
And if you make the dinner, there's definitely something wrong, it just wasn't cooked the
way they wanted.
That's the pricks coming back at you.
To be a rose without torns is to have this extraordinary humility.
And it's amazing that person is very easy to live with.
I know people like that, they're so easy to live with.
Because torns are given by one who has them, ouch.
So you don't prick other people unless you have the prickly inside of you.
Now it's not told to us in the most charitable manner.
But if one doesn't have one, how can you give them?
Not only this, but humility is a flower which strengthens and clears one's sight.
You have to put a huge NB beside that, absolutely, that's utterly vital.
Humility clears the internal spiritual vision.
And our internal vision is clouded by all kinds of things to do itself, all kinds of
faults and failings that we have, which of course we think is everybody else's faults
and failings, because we project unto others, okay?
Humility gives you the ability to actually see what you're looking at.
And that's by definition of discernment.
Discernment is that you see what you're looking at.
So if I hold up this bottle of water and say to you that it's made of glass, the bottle,
then you say there's something wrong with Francis because if your eyesight is better,
you know better.
But okay, so humility gives you the ability to be able to see things for what they really
are.
And I remember a conversation that Pope John Paul II had with university students in Germany
a number of years ago, in which they asked him to tell them how to be Christian in society
as it is today.
Now he said a number of things, but the thing that really stayed with me was he said, call
everything by its real name.
That's the discernment you see.
He said, call sin, sin.
Then you'll never fall into it, call grace, grace, call life, life, call death, death.
Call everything by its real name.
He said, you won't trip.
There's the vigilance of someone being able to actually see correctly.
So humility is the flower that strengthens and clears one's sight.
And with its clearness, it knows how to stay away from the thorns themselves as well.
Okay.
So March the second, 1905, Jesus gives Louisa the key to his will.
This is a huge thing.
Continuing in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself and I found myself with
the key in my hand.
And even though I was covering a long way, and sometimes I would get distracted, even
she admits that, yet as soon as I would think about the key, I would always find it in my
hand.
Now, this is a very simple picture that she's been given, that if we keep remembering the
divine will, we'll always come back to the center.
Now, she gets it pictorially so that she can pass it on to us very, very simply if it was
given to you in a high intellectual statement, you might think it was difficult.
Let me illustrate what she is getting.
If in my hand I'm holding this bottle of water, I'm not going to forget a drink, am
I?
No, because it's in my hand.
And she's saying if the divine will is in your hand or you're holding on to it, you're
not going to forget, you'll keep coming back to it.
Is that okay?
Because I believe that once you illustrate these things, it's fine, you understand then.
So now I could see that this key served to open a palace, that's the palace of the divine
will.
And inside that there was the baby Jesus sleeping.
But I could see everything from afar and I was all in haste in a hurry to go there and
open it for fear that he might wake up, that he might cry, or he would not find me near
him.
So I hastened more and more and when I got there just about to go up, I found myself inside
of myself that she's back out of the ecstasy and I remain concerned.
However, afterwards when blessed Jesus came, he said, "My daughter, the key that you always
found in your hand is the key of my will, which I have placed in your hands and one who
has an object in his hand can do with it whatever they want."
So you can do the most wonderful things with the divine will if you're holding on to it.
Okay.
Now, notice he gives you the divine will and then you can decide what you want to do with
it.
You can decide how many souls you want to save and all the rest of it.
It's incredible.
So March the 5th, 1905 is just a sentence.
As I was suffering a little more than usual, blessed Jesus came for a little and told me,
"My daughter, the cross is the support of the weak, the strength of the strong and the
seed and the custody of virginity."
In other words, the cross really protects you from harm, whatever state you're in.
Okay.
So March the 20th, 1905, true love and true virtue must have their origin in God.
If they don't have their origin in God, they're not really much use.
Okay.
"Continue in my usual state, blessed Jesus came for just a little and he told me, 'My daughter,
the love which does not have its origin in God cannot be called true love.'
Because on earth, we call lots of things love, whether they are or whether they're not.
The world outside calls something love and if you pull back the label, you read L-U-S-T.
But they call it love.
Am I right or wrong?
How do you know it's lost?
By their fruits, you will know them.
It's as simple as that.
If it was love, our society would be an incredible society.
Half the nation wouldn't be in hospital, okay?
We would have families that were not breaking apart.
We would have schools that would be operating correctly.
We'd have hospitals that are operating correctly.
We'd have a society that was totally strong because the strength of a people is the moral
strength of the nation.
Sorry, the strength of a nation is the moral strength of its people.
That's something that's been known forever.
And so, if what they're calling love out there was actually correct, you'd have all
of these results.
But if the place is disintegrating, then you know it's not love.
It's something else.
That's what he means by its origin, it's not in God.
So you talk about false love there.
Okay, the love which does not have its origin in God cannot be called true love.
And the virtues themselves, which do not have their origin in God, are falsified virtues.
That means people are leaning on their own human nature to be good.
And if you're leaning on human nature without grace, you're not going very far.
Look at a movement that has been happening in Ireland over the past 20 years.
We won't go back any further than that.
And that is a movement away from God, away from grace.
And what do you have daily murders?
It's a sure sign.
Human beings are not able to be good without grace, without God.
You just can't do it.
Look at Genesis chapter three.
They broke the relationship with God, Genesis chapter four, first murder.
That's how it is.
And the murder simply means that you see this almost daily in Ireland.
The murder simply means that when two people have a difficulty with each other, all the
feelings get out of control.
The person did not intend to kill that one.
We're hearing this in the courts every day, aren't we?
But they drank too much or whatever it is, and now they can't control their feelings
and they lash out with somebody else, and they have a body as a result.
So no grace count the bodies.
All right.
So if it doesn't have their origin in God, it's false.
Indeed, everything which does not have its origin in God can be called neither love nor
virtue, but rather a parent light or false light that ends up converting into darkness.
Now I want to give you Matthew chapter five, verses 29 and 30, where Jesus says if your
eye causes you to sin, if your hand causes you to sin, do you remember?
If your foot causes you to sin.
Matthew five, 29 to 30.
And what you think is light ends up in darkness.
Okay.
When he added, for example, a confessor who works and sacrifices himself very much for
his soul is something holy.
It apparently gives of heroism.
And yet if he does so because he obtained or hopes to obtain something, the origin of
the sacrifice is not in God but himself.
He's only serving himself.
Is that okay?
And the awful thing is in these writings, the Lord will show you that you can have in
other people's eyes, you may be a very holy person and God's eyes are nothing because
the motivation is all wrong.
And if the motivation for self is there, forget about it.
The action has no value in God's eyes.
So the intention is everything, but we got that very much given to us in volumes one
to four, about the intention, the intention, the intention, okay.
So let's go on to March 23, 1905, glory and satisfaction of Jesus.
As I was in my usual state, blessed Jesus came for a little and I said to him, "Lord,
what is my state, Lord, is my state, sorry, your glory?"
And he said, "My daughter, all my glory and my satisfaction is solely that I want the
whole of you more in me."
Now that's Deuteronomy 6 verses 4 to 10.
I want the whole of you.
Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10 says, "Hero Israel, the Lord your God is one Lord, and you shall
love the Lord your God with all your heart, all your soul, all your mind, and all your
being underlying all the alls."
What a lover never wants 80% of the beloved, do they?
No, they want the whole of the person because that's what love is, love seeks union, love
seeks oneness, okay.
Then he added, "Everything is in the soul's distrust and fear of herself and her trust
and confidence in God."
Now Proverbs 3, 5, "My son, lean not on your own understanding, trust in God."
Proverbs 3, 5, it's one of the famous statements of the Old Testament.
So what we're being told here is that you do not rely on yourself, you rely on God.
As you go on in these writings, the Lord is going to show you, you don't even look at
your miseries or your faults and your failings.
Look at Jesus only and love him only and he will bring you to great sanctity.
He will bring you to great sanctity, it's actually not difficult.
I should say it's not difficult to understand, it's just difficult to do if you love yourself
too much.
So March the 28th, 1905, now you remember volumes 1 to 4 all the time, Jesus was telling her,
"Do not allow disturbance on the inside."
So we're going to get a message about that again.
And Louisa said, "As I was in my usual state, blessed Jesus came for just a little.
And since I had said to a soul that was disturbed, think of not wanting to be disturbed.
Not only for your own good, but more so out of love for our Lord.
Because a soul who is disturbed is not only disturbed herself, what makes Jesus Christ
disturbed."
Now that means that you disturb the action of God in yourself.
Now if you're disturbed on the inside, it allows Satan to move in to attempt.
And human beings have an instinct that when a person is down, they kick them, "Am I right
or am I right?"
Yeah.
So this disturbance on the inside is very dangerous.
Let me give you an illustration.
If there's a storm outside here, you look out but it's not in the room.
It's not on the inside.
So you can survive.
You can outlive the storm.
You can deal with it.
But if the storm comes into the room, then you have a huge problem.
You've got to get out of the room.
That's why if the storm or the disturbance comes on the inside into your inner being,
then God isn't able to move in but Satan moves in very fast to pull you down.
Is that all right?
Yes.
So this disturbance is very important.
That's why when we give spiritual direction to people, we say to them, "Now is the problem
on the outside or the inside?"
And initially they look at you and I explain about the storm and then if they say the problem
is on the outside, "Oh, that's okay, we'll talk it through."
You're all right.
You're actually okay if it's on the outside and not on the inside.
And I know some people in divine will who have been tried and tested to an absolutely,
in my opinion, heroic degree and they have total peace, the peace that passes all understanding
on the inside.
The storm is outside of them, even if the storm is in the family, okay?
The storm is outside of them.
They still have the peace that passes all understanding on the inside.
Therefore the Lord can do incredible things for that family through this person.
How do you get it?
Because the Lord is enthroned in that household once this person keeps the Lord's throne untouched.
You just have to see the logic of what we're doing, okay?
So later I said to myself what Nonsense Louisa said, "Jesus can never be disturbed."
Then on coming he told me, "My daughter instead of Nonsense," he actually spoke the truth.
In fact, in each soul I form a divine life.
He by locates himself in us is the way we're told about it in the higher volumes.
And if the soul is disturbed, this divine life that I keep forming also remains disturbed.
Not only this, but it never comes to being properly completed, okay?
So for that I want to give you, first of all Ephesians 2, 10, where God's work of art,
and he keeps trying to perfect us, Ephesians 2, 10.
And the other one I want to give you is Philippians 1, 6, that the Lord will complete a work
in us if we allow him to do it.
But he says very clearly in volumes 1 to 4 that he can only work in peace because he's
a God of peace.
And so if there's disturbance on the inside, it does block it.
Louisa said, "Then I continued my usual interior work on the passion.
And as I reached the point of the encounter of Jesus and Mary on the way of the cross,
he made himself seen again and told me, 'My daughter, the soul, also, I encounter continuously.
And if the encounter I make with the soul, I find her in the act of exercising virtues
and united with me, she repays me for the sorrow I suffered when I encountered my mother
so sorrowful because of me.'
So he's saying that he meets you and I at every single second of your life.
Make sure you place the intention at some point that you want to meet him with adoration,
praise, honor, glory and so on, that you actually tell him, 'I want to meet you every time
with this approach coming from me,' because placing the intention is extremely important.
So April the 11th, 1905, how perseverance is the seal of eternal life.
Now, perseverance is extremely important.
You probably know that Mount Everest is littered with gear left behind by people who thought
they were going to have the time of their lives and they were going to conquer a mountain.
And there are three stages on the way up.
Okay.
And actually, it's the most wonderful parable because there are three stages in the spiritual
life.
And at stage one, most of the ones who were really properly prepared managed to get past
stage one but some people didn't and went back from stage one but they actually went
back with all their equipment because they weren't too high.
Stage two, vast majority turned back but they couldn't carry the equipment because the
air wasn't strong enough.
And so the place is littered with human equipment.
Stage three has more junk than anywhere else where people were so close to the goal and
they just couldn't make it.
And I've seen John of the Cross doesn't talk about Mount Everest, the before guy I probably
didn't know about it either.
He was in the 16th century but he said that the greatest tragedy in the spiritual life
is that crowds begin, very few finish.
And the real tragedy is how many stop about four yards from the goal.
In other words, you stop just before you win.
That's the tragedy of us.
We can say, "Look, I'm tired, I've had enough blah, blah, blah."
And so perseverance is extremely important and Jesus speaks about it quite a lot in volumes
one to four and he comes back again on it here.
Louisa says, "Being very afflicted because of the privation of my adorable Jesus, I was
saying to myself, 'How cruel he has become with me.'
I myself cannot understand how his good heart can reach the point of doing this."
And now this is volume six, she does know that the privation is because he's chastising
and all the rest of it.
But you know, we're not very logical in our emotions, are we?
Your head can say that, and all the rest of it, what your emotions are completely different.
We are very like small children, spiritually.
And a small child who's told that the mother has gone down to the shop to get milk for the
child will be at the window thinking she's gone forever.
She's only gone five minutes, the shop's only down the road, but the child cannot tolerate
the absence of the mother.
Does that make sense?
So the child gets into a crisis, if the mother stops to talk to a neighbor, she has a real
crisis when she comes home.
But you know that if you left her little doggy for a day or two as well, the doggy will get
into a crisis as well, giving you the same reaction.
Okay.
Now spiritually we're like that.
And so while logically Louisa knows that he's chastising, that's not where she's at.
And as far as she's concerned, he's abandoned me.
Okay.
And you know, if she read her own writings, she'd be amazed at how often she says it.
Do you know what I mean?
Well, spiritually, it's like as if we live the whole of our lives in one day, just as
children do.
And therefore, if you feel you're not able to contact the Lord today, you think it's
all over and done with.
I mean, I've had over the years, I've had many people come and tell me it's all over.
It was only a bubble.
It was fantastic while it was going on.
But it's all over.
I say, what's all over?
I always remember one particular person, she was in a real tizzy about it.
And she'd had a wonderful charismatic experience and everything was grand for years.
And now it was all dried off, you see.
And I said, you sound like someone telling a counselor that the honeymoon's over and
you've got to get down with the ordinary everyday life.
And the washing is waiting for you.
And the floor has to be cleaned and the children have to be taken care of and everything.
And the wonderful emotional high that you had and can't have everyday because that's
not real life.
And she looked at me and I said, you're going to smile, come on, do yourself the favor of
smiling.
You're having reality therapy.
This is one day morning, it's not Sunday.
Okay.
And we're like that spiritually, that's the only reason why I'm saying it.
We think that it will never come back and you hear Louise is saying that all the time,
it's fascinating.
Okay.
But beside it, because she's really suffering, I want to put Sam 22 verses one to four.
My God, my God, why have you forsaken me, do you remember?
So while I was saying this and other nonsense, all of a sudden he came and he said, indeed,
one of the soul which pleases me the most is perseverance, okay, because perseverance
is the seal of eternal life and the development of divine life, perseverance.
Okay.
Now I want to give you Hebrews 12 verses one to four.
And I want to give you Luke 18, it would be verses one to 10 for the widow and the unjust
judge.
You remember, she persevered under she got it.
You have another lady and I think, I don't know whether she's in Luke 18 or not as well.
The sire of Venetian woman who wouldn't let Jesus off the hook and Jesus seemed to insult
her and everything.
And she said, it's all right.
You can say what you like.
I still want you to heal my daughter, it's okay.
I think she's fantastic.
She absolutely fantastic.
She wouldn't take any rebukes.
Sorry?
Matthew?
That would be in Luke and as well, sire of Venetian woman.
So these are people who persevered and you also have teaching in Luke 11, the teaching
on prayer in which you're told to persevere.
And do you remember the man arriving in the middle of the night and he's told to go away
because the children are getting disturbed.
But he perseveres and he gets the bread to keep the kids asleep.
So that was the motivation given to him.
He says, right, you can keep them asleep if you give me the bread.
So the perseverance is terribly important.
And as we go on in these volumes, you'll find a number of examples just in the volumes
following this where Louisa intercedes with Jesus and she will not let him off the hook.
She says, okay.
And then she goes on and if he gives her what in any way could be taught as a rebuke, she
still goes on and she perseveres and she perseveres and she gets what she asks for.
So perseverance is extremely important.
Do you remember St. Augustine or beauty so ancient and so new later?
I loved thee.
Okay.
He's ever old and ever new.
And immutable, that means never changes.
That's the problem that people have when society goes into rebellion as our society has gone
into rebellion against God.
God never changes and they think that God's law should change because they've changed.
And when God's law doesn't change because they've changed, then they persecute because
they've got bad consciences.
Okay.
So God is ever old and ever new and immutable.
In the same way through perseverance by having exercised it always, the soul is old and by
her attitude of exercising it ever new, in other words like God, okay.
And each time she exercises that she's renewed in God, remaining immutable and without realizing
it.
Since through perseverance she continuously acquires divine life within herself.
By acquiring God she is sealed with eternal life.
That means you die and you go to heaven.
Now in the higher volumes Jesus says that 9 out of 10 people on this planet go to purgatory
if they've done at least the minimum required, do you know what I mean?
What he also says that someone genuinely living the divine will go straight to heaven, purgatory
is not for them.
Can there be a seal safer than God himself?
And Louisa will tell you that when St. Hannibal de Francea actually went to heaven that the
saints were shocked at him bringing the glory of God with him and bringing the presence of
the divine will with him and bringing all of the wonderful things that went with it, okay.
So we'll go to the next one which is April the 16th, 1905 and notice that the title is
suffering is raining.
That's not how we look at suffering is it?
Continue in my usual state my beloved Jesus made himself seen for a little with a nail
inside of his heart and drawing near to my heart he would touch it with that nail and
I would feel mortal pains.
Then he said to me my daughter it is the world that drives this nail deep into my heart giving
me continuous death want to give you one John two fifteen one John two fifteen.
So by justice, just as they give me continuous death I will allow that they give death among
themselves.
This is 1905.
What is he talking about world war one, okay.
I will allow that they give death among themselves killing one another like many dogs.
I think 70 million were killed in world war one and while saying this he made me hear
the screams of the rebel to the point that I remain deafened for four or five days imagine.
And then as I was very much in suffering he came back a little later and he told me today
is the day of the of the palms in which I was proclaimed king.
All must aspire to a kingdom but in order to acquire the eternal kingdom it is necessary
for the creature to acquire the power over herself through the dominion of our passions.
You notice I adjusted the text there, do you see it?
We have to have power over ourselves to get dominion over the passions.
The only means is suffering because suffering is raining that is through patience man puts
himself in his place becoming king of himself and of his eternal kingdom.
This is ruling over yourself, okay, and the Lord says that if we don't rule over ourselves
we have no right to rule over anybody else.
We don't even know what ruling is, do we?
We don't even know what authority is.
And in these writings and in the writings of the other saints Jesus says that to have
dominion over yourself is to be a king or an emperor on the earth.
And there are people with big high jobs in government and all the rest of it.
And if they're not ruling over themselves then he says they're worse than slaves, okay.
We'll do one more and then we'll take a break.
April the 20th, 1905 in these times humanity is like a bone out of place.
A bone out of place doesn't feel good does it?
As I was in my usual state, Louisa said, "Blessed Jesus came for just a little, almost in the
act of chastising the people."
And he said, "My daughter, creatures lacerate my flesh, they trample upon my body continuously,
and I will permit that their flesh be lacerated and their blood dispersed."
Because you know in these writings you're told that sin rises up from the earth.
God has a post office up there and he says return to sender.
So sin rises up and comes back to the earth as chastisement.
In other words, we create the chastisement because nothing or unholy or unworthy can
enter the presence of God, it's that simple.
So sin cannot penetrate into the heavens, it's not allowed.
And so it comes back to the earth.
And if there's too much sin, the earth rebels against us.
So you have water rebelling against us in tsunamis.
You have the earth rebelling against us in volcanoes and earthquakes.
You have the air rebelling against us in hurricanes and so on.
But it's created by us.
And we shouldn't be giving out about climate change, we should be looking for change inside
of ourselves.
So in these times, humanity is like a bone out of place, out of its center.
And in order to put it in its place again and to make it re-enter into its center, it is
necessary that it be undone.
Now if I give you that in modern language, a surgeon will say to you, I can put you back
again but I have to take you apart first.
I have to do this major thing inside of you.
There will be life afterwards, it's going to be very uncomfortable, it'll take a long
time to recover and blah, blah, blah.
But if we don't do it, you get worse and worse and it's death.
Then calming himself a little, he added my daughter.
The soul can know whether she has dominated her passions.
If touched by temptations or by people, very often it's people, isn't it, she does not
take it into consideration.
In other words, you're not prickly and everything that people say or do to you is not a crisis.
For example, she's tempted to impurity.
If she has dominated this passion, the soul doesn't take it into consideration and her
very nature remains in its place, so there's the temptation to lust.
On the other hand, she hasn't taken control.
The soul becomes annoyed and she afflicts herself, you get upset because you're going
to struggle and she feels a rotten stream flow within her body or one person mortifies
or insults someone else and this one has dominated the passion of pride.
She remains at peace and therefore it's not a problem.
But of course, if pride hasn't been put in its place, there's a huge problem, isn't
there?
Because if pride is dominating, then you take insults where they weren't intended.
If on the other hand, she hasn't put it in its place, she feels a stream of fire indignation
of pride within herself which turns her completely upside down and that's the origin of many
of these homicides that are happening in Ireland today.
In fact, when the passion is there, at the occasion it comes out into the field and so
all the rest.
In other words, if we're to get anywhere in life, let alone anywhere in the spiritual
life and even more so anywhere in the divine will, we have got to be people who reign over
this little kingdom inside of us, is that okay?
You can't do it by yourself, John 15.5, but you can do it with Jesus and a very simple
thing if you're in trouble or temptation is to say Jesus, cover me with your precious
blood so that you and I together can conquer this thing.
I can't do it by myself, but you and I can do it together because he wants you involved.
So I'll give you a break.